we talked about text subtext in context
what does each item mean yeah well
that's a big subject text subtext in
context so ultimately it is about a
character wanting something right
every stories about a character wants
them wanting something and then facing a
conflict to get it whether they get it
or not so when they want something they
have a desire that desire is expressed
through subtext if I want this glass of
water I'm going to take the action right
so the subtext is that you can infer I'm
thirsty or I'm looking for some sort of
like physical distraction to keep my
hands busy or something like that and
the gulping is part of that too maybe
there's I'm about to confront you on
something yes sir you know or I'm your
boss or you know whatever I'm an
ex-girlfriend me there's just so many
things and anything you're like you know
yeah exactly she's gonna say to me so a
lot of that is about interpreting we we
are guessing what a character wants from
the behaviors they're exhibiting right
now the context is simply the worldview
the situation they're dealing with right
so we're sitting in a room right now we
have we all have different objectives
and so that this the when the character
so the context is literally just like
the plate that you're serving everything
on like I compare it like visually I
came up with a metaphor of creme brulee
just use a visual metaphor where you've
got the plate as the context and then
you've got the brulee or the the creme
the cream as the subtext and then the
the top layer that's burned and scorched
brûléed is the text oh that's great so
the idea is basically what we're seeing
is words right and those words often are
in complete contradiction of actual
intention but in some way we're
interpreting those words as a kind of
behavior so most of the time like for
example it's part of the reason
when I'm writing the last thing I do is
write dialogue that was another thing I
learned from Ron Mita you want to be
able to well do whatever you want but
for me I like to have the characters
intentions very clear and the conflict
that they're gonna be facing very clear
and what we're constantly trying to do
is there's this one there's a one book
called character and viewpoint where it
talks about how essentially you know
we're all like chimpanzees in the wild
and when they're in when they're in the
jungle and they sense that there's a
threat they run away and the first thing
they do as soon as they feel like
they're safe the very first thing they
do is they stop they turn around to see
where the source of danger is so that's
when they're completely engaged the
whole chimpanzee metaphor is basically
that we're trying to interpret the
intention of things that are around us
so we're we're we're projecting what we
think that person wants by the way it's
behaving so we're trying to determine
whether it's a threat or whether it's
safe whether it's one on our side or
against us that kind of thing so
ultimately what we're looking for with
like with with dialog is we're trying to
see if we can believe them and the most
interesting characters are completely
unaware of what's actually driving them
you know like they're the whole time
like Indiana Jones is going through all
of these ridiculous hoops not really
like the whole time we were wondering
like why is he taking on these Nazis why
is it being dragged by a chair just so
that like some something and make it
into a museum ultimately he has this
really you know stuff that depends how
deep you want to go with Indiana Jones
but he has this kind of drive to it it's
genuinely emotionally upsetting to him
that there would be some betrayal some
misrepresentation of the truth and
that's what's interesting is so like the
whole time he's making all these really
bold choices you think he's kind of this
glib sarcastic professor but um what
he's really doing is
he's trying to unearth truth and he's
trying like he's literally putting his
body under all his brutality because he
wants to the truth to be revealed and
that's you know and every single choice
you know that because every single
choice whether he admits it or not has
led toward him exposing the truth for
what it is so which is better
subtext or context because we know the
less you sort of tell it's like saying
which is better the trigger or the
bullet okay all right okay so maybe
which which is the best to focus on
maybe I'm misunderstanding some of what
because text I get subtext yeah it makes
sense when you said you took you went to
take the drink well then I can infer
that maybe you're thirsty or maybe
you're using it as a buffer yes subtext
is an expression of the desire okay
right and the text is it's only one
means of expressing that desire sure
instead of saying I'm thirsty and then
you but by doing it it's much more
believable or I realize that you're
needing that glass for some reason but
then the context I think is where I'm
like just trying to figure that out a
little bit more so the context would be
okay so for example okay take a simple
line go ahead drink it right so go ahead
drink it is the text okay we can add
different subtext to it so if I say go
ahead drink it there's a different
subtext I'm sure maybe threatening you
right go ahead drink it right I'm saying
I don't really care what you do if I say
go ahead [ __ ] drink it right I change
the text a little bit but the subtext is
totally different now so that's text
than subtext context is we're sitting in
a bus I'm holding a gun this is a clumsy
way I'm holding a gun and you're holding
poison and I'm holding your child
so now the context is extremely loaded
and then the choice that you're about to
make is implicit and I'm saying if you
don't drink it I'm gonna shoot your baby
so I say go ahead drink it see the
context he has this story the context is
a situation you're dealing with we can
come up with a much better that's just
that comes in but the idea is that
basically like the text is the
ironically because writers tend to
overemphasize dialogues so much the text
tends to get too much importance the
most important stuff is the context and
the subtext because the subtext is the
intention the context is the conflict
that you're dealing with the situation
you're trying to deal with so if we're
in space and we're flying toward the
moon and we know that is gravity I don't
know I'm just making this up as we go if
we're flying toward the moon and we know
that this is that the only thing that's
going to save us is this little serum
and it could either boil our blood or it
might save our lives and we've just
given up and we've been through this
whole journey and we were about to open
the hatch and I say go ahead drink it
then we open the hatch it totally
changes the whole context so that the
context is about the situation you're
dealing with subtext is intention text
is just the artifacts it's one
expression of that desire
you